[Musique]
une foule dense
partis de la place de la république la
mobilisation contre la sécurité globale
s'amplifient c'est le président de la
république qui organise lui même ce
désordre pour faire mine de le combattre
ensuite par quelques tweets mais ça ne
suffit pas de faire quelques tweets émis
pour dire qu' il est inadmissible qu'on
frappe un homme part des forces de
police placement en détention provisoire
des trois premiers policiers a été
requis en considération du trouble
exceptionnel et persistant à l'ordre
public provoqué par la gravité de
l'infraction des circonstances de sa
commission et de l'importance du
préjudice qu'elle a causés alors que le
cortège se dirige vers la place de la
bastille un face-à-face s'engage entre
un groupe de personnes masquées et les
forces de l'ordre
il n'ya qu'une réponse aujourd'hui pour
apaiser le pays s'est pas seulement le
retrait de l'article 24 c'est le retrait
de cette loi il y encore quelques mois
quand nous parlions de violences
policières nous étions bien seul et
monsieur darmana nous refuser les mots
lui qui maintenant veut nous refuser les
images quand jean luc mélenchon avait
parlé de barbares s'agissant de pratique
précise vous étiez tous sortis du bois
en dix ans de service les tensions
s'exacerbent lors de la dispersion
les forces de l'ordre sont visés par des
slogans hostiles
soyez fiers d'être des amateurs avait
t-il dit à ses ministres et à sa
majorité
c'est du travail d'amateur être capable
sur un sujet comme celui ci avec une
demande aussi légitime d'ajouter une
crise politique à la crise sanitaire que
nous connaissons à la crise sécuritaire
oui c'est du travail d'amateur il
faudrait être sourd pour ne pas
l'entendre que ce que nous avons
aujourd'hui proposer et voter pour
assurer cette protection n'est pas
satisfaisant donc évidemment qu'il faut
revoir notre copie qu'il faut
retravailler
ça veut dire que le président de
république doit choisir il doit dire
s'il est darmanin s'il est l'allemand ou
si au contraire il est un républicain
qui s'assume je suis pas l'avocat de
gérald darmanin je ne serais
certainement pas son procureur j'aurai
des reproches à lui faire
s'il n'avait pas pris cette décision
s'il n'avait pas annoncé l'autre jour
directement qu'il proposerait à l'issue
de l'enquète la révocation
là il aurait failli à sa mission ça n'a
pas été le cas
encore une fois la loi est en
construction
malheureusement je suis prête alors si
on révèle des sous titres à ce que vous
dites
juridiquement aujourd'hui ça n'est pas
le temps de cela nous venons de le voter
à l'assemblée nationale le gouvernement
n'a pas le droit de supprimer comme ça
un article d'un texte voté par
l'assemblée nationale
sinon il ya plus besoin de parlement et
le gouvernement ne décide pas d'un trait
de plume ce qui est maintenu dans un
texte qui a été voté par l'assemblée
nationale et ce qu'ils en retirent je
demande la démission ou le limogeage du
préfet l'allemand qui a en plus pour lui
le bilan du traitement des gilet jaune
avec 32 personnes éborgné dont on n'a
toujours pas retrouvé la trace avec
cette mascarade qui est devenu l'igpn
dans laquelle des policiers décident
entre du sort de policiers
le reportage d'envoyé spécial à l'époque
je me souviens ou sur 378 propositions
et comment pleins ya que deux
propositions qui avaient été envoyés au
parquet par l'igpn ce qui donne quand
même quelques doutes sur la possibilité
se faire mais on ne peut pas être juge
et partie d'autres bombes à
fragmentation qui nous attendent
la réforme des retraites oui
mes relations pour te connaître agissez
vis-à-vis de police ces antennes les
médias français en trois endroits du
tout
via la loi sur l'université qui regarde
quand même les libertés académiques dont
celle qui remonte parfois même jusqu'au
moyen-âge et qui prévoit la condamnation
d'un an de prison pour les étudiants qui
vont manifester
il est temps de procéder à une reprise
en main général de la police et pour
mieux dire être encore plus clair à une
refonte
parfois il me disait ah parlement